herbert o meine fragen
wie wer bist du eigentlich
und die andere frage wer wie viel mag
ist unter woche trainieren gehst du
dreimal viermal so und ja das war es
auch
eine coole frage ich wie 100 also mal
zwischen 100 und 103 kilo einer woche ja
ich würde ich sagen dass ich ein
richtiger als dass ich mache nicht
richtig findet sich der nabu zulassungen
punkten halt immer nachts aber teil
boxen habe ich jetzt schon dreimal die
woche
und ja also dreimal die woche trainieren
schön viel schicken essen bisschen fehlt
uns noch und dann gesagt dass
keine anderen musiker oder leute auf
keinen fall hier haben wir diesen
anabolika ich habe früher ich war so ein
dünner spargeltarzan du musst einfach
nur vernünftig essen viel milch trinken
haben wir haben diesen anabolika zu
glauben hier werde das wollen und ihr
denkt ihr kriegt damit mehr frauen über
genug gesagt aber napoli kann da etwas
anderes kleiner und dann bringt das auch
nicht meine frau